Okay, we are recording and we are live on our Zoom call 10-3-13-2018. I'm not muted any money,
so if you guys want to jump in with any questions to begin with, I don't have anything specific
that I want to talk about. I did record an anxiety video of dealing with anxiety already that
I need to re-record. I think the audio got messed up on it, so I'll try to do that later
tomorrow morning. So, any questions, we'll take questions. I'll probably mute you guys to answer them
so that we don't get feedback during the answers. Dr. Collins, I have one. I was listening to
Dr. Ben Lynch. Anyway, he was saying that how long do we take our supplements before we can stop taking
them, that they may, that they've done their job, were healed and et cetera.
Oh, good question. Can you hear me now?
Yeah, thank you. Okay. Okay, Deb, try not to get, I could not hear your question at all.
Wrong again. Okay. Can you hear me, Deb? Yeah, is that better? Yeah, I just had to be with somebody else
that were getting feedback. So, go ahead. Okay, I was listening to Dr. Ben Lynch today
and he was saying how some people, they were talking about autoimmune diseases.
And he said supplementation, he has some people of healed about, healed with it.
How do we, and cancer is, you know, the end end of the, I want to say the most
death for time we need the supplements. But how do we know when we can stop taking our supplements
and that the things our body healed, the areas that we're trying to support?
Well, it partly depends on what you're taking supplements for.
So, if I'm taking supplements for, let's say, a gut issue, and my gut issue is resolved.
I don't have those symptoms anymore. I could start taking less.
Okay, I'll do that.
So, I don't know what's wrong with my audio.
So, there's lots of, lots of reasons why I would maybe decrease taking a supplement, if I'm healed from that condition.
And the condition is a grave condition that I would stop taking the supplementation.
If I, if the supplement again put my cancer into revision, then I think I would continue to take that supplement.
So, if I could use some wisdom there and you could also do testing, whether it's kinesiology,
testing or some other testing to help make that decision.
Okay, thank you.
Any other questions?
Hi, this is Dennis Baldridge. I posted on Facebook and I haven't had a chance to look.
So, if you've answered there, just tell me to go and look at Facebook, but we can get organic produce now.
But as winter comes along, it's hard to get in our rural community, any good organic produce.
So, at that point, what do you do at that point?
Can you guys hear me?
I can.
Okay.
All right, because I lost Dennis there.
I don't know what's going on with her internet connection, maybe.
But yeah, you just kind of do the best you can. I did answer that on Facebook already, but you have to do the best you can.
You're not always going to be able to get organic fresh produce at different times of the year.
And there is some wisdom in eating in season.
Just that in the past two of learning to eat what's in season.
Maybe we're not supposed to eat apples all year long. Maybe we're not supposed to necessarily eat broccoli all year long.
So having a rotational diet can have can be beneficial too.
So try to stick to that clean 15 dirty dozen list as best you can.
The problem is, is even if you stick to organic foods, you're going to get pesticides and chemicals in it.
You just kind of do the best you can.
Any other questions?
No.
Nothing.
No other questions?
That's all right.
I've got one more question here.
And you buy you and I have, we've referenced this before when I was there for my two day treatment.
But I went to my own a college was a couple of days ago, or are they discouraging?
I mean, you're ago, they were telling me I had six months to live.
And if I take their drug, I live an extra six months. Now they're saying, I've got about a year to live.
And if I take their drugs, I'll live two more years.
How do we deal with that?
I mean, they keep saying my cancer is going to come back.
I mean, I'm just frustrated with, with that, on a colleges.
Sure.
Yeah, that's understandable.
And my belief is that no one has the right to tell you how many years you've got to live,
but once you got to live, that's if God's hailed.
So you got to, you got to recognize an untruth when you hear it too.
And I understand that they're trying to, many times, have your best interests at heart.
And in their mind, they're thinking that the way that they have to treat with the tools that they have
and their pocket are the only tools that exist.
They don't really do it outside of what their recommendations are.
Because that's how they've been taught.
And they can only, they can only teach what they don't.
So you got to balance that out with, with seeking, you know, counsel from the multitude of people,
and to recognize that, you know, your God is in control of your head days.
So sometimes it's appropriate to do a chemo there.
But sometimes it's appropriate to do what they want you to do.
Sometimes it's not appropriate to do what they want you to do.
And then you just kind of make that decision.
So, but I also understand that sometimes you go to their college and get very discouraging.
I would highly recommend that, if you need that, you need anybody, regardless of the doctor,
and you feel discouraged because of it.
And it's not, it's not lifted you up and given you hope,
that you make sure that you pray about that last meeting that you had,
so that you don't let the spirit of discouragement or worry or anxiety come upon you
and bring you down.
I just say, no, I don't accept that.
And the name of Jesus, I'm not going to take that.
And the Lord just cleans me from that and move on from it.
And forgive them.
I recommend that you just forgive them.
They're coming from what they know and what they think is best for you.
And that's all they can teach you.
And try to use your next appointment as an opportunity to minister to them.
I'm doing some other things.
I know God's got his hand on my life.
I know you told me last time that I was going to only live six months if I didn't knew your treatment.
And here it's a year later.
I want to tell you why.
And maybe somebody's going to be open to that and want to hear your story.
And it's a chance for you to give your testimony.
And this is how we can bring glory to God through the midst of our suffering.
This is just another way we could do that.
And just be open to whatever God has for you there.
Dr. Connors.
I have another question.
I'm having trouble with this.
I'll kinker sores and crypto.
It's at that black tongue.
That fungus that puts that black.
Black on your tongue and it says this no cardio and crypto.
I don't know.
Caucus.
I can't pronounce it.
Yeah.
Anyway, it keeps going and coming.
It's a good indication that yes, I'm.
I'm stressing myself at times.
And no, I'm not stressing at my time.
Other times.
Yeah, there can be lots of reasons for that.
It could be a pH of balance in your belt.
Especially if you get it with corn sores too.
Is that what you're getting?
Corn sores with it also.
Yes.
Well, cold sores are.
There are really a big indication that your pH of your belt.
You can really get it with corn.
You can really get a seed of your belt.
That's a good indication that your.
Is it acidic?
So we've been taking like a calcium.
I'm a little.
And just kind of sucking on it.
Can help.
A lot to bring that balance in.
And that can help balance that.
Because that will be alkalizing to your bones.
Even putting a little baking soda in your belt.
Putting a little.
You know, link your figure and.
And then other things like themes, oil could help with the bacteria, running the bacterial
program in the rife can be beneficial.
I think grapefruit seed extract can be beneficial.
You're just going to try different things because different bacteria can be developed at a beauty towards things too.
So it's definitely not viral as bacterial.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, um, what's that?
L-I-Z worked for me with cold sores.
That's right. L-I-Z will work as well.
L-I-Z works better on a take it out of regular basis to help keep cold sores at bay.
Um, so that's another thing that could be beneficial to good.
Good.
You know, I don't remember the milligram dose.
Um, I don't have any L-I-Z that I carry.
You're going to have to look for that in a, in a health food store.
Um, there's a thousand milligrams. I'm not sure.
Okay.
I can't remember.
Thank you.
Dr. Cutters.
It's Lisa Nagel.
I have a question.
Um, I know there's always been a lot of talk about lymphatic.
Um, my tumor is in my right breast and a few times it's felt fuller.
Harder.
And I, and then it would, you know, I'd say it ebbs and flows.
And now what I think I've found is it has something to do with my lymphatic.
I think.
Um, not that I feel any lymph nodes under my arm or anything like that.
Um, I did a sauna.
I went for a walk like I sweated twice in the day, moved twice.
I mean, I do the dry brushing and, um, all of that.
And after the sauna, the infrared sauna, and the walking and sweating,
it's like it, the inflammation went down.
So I'm just wondering if, like, because that tumor is there and just,
like, is that an also, like it is just on that side.
It's not on the other side with the lymphatic.
Um, I don't know, just the tumor and the lymphatic.
Is that like a weak spot or a spot that the lymphatic wants to hang out?
Like, not do it.
You see, get stuck there.
That's one question.
And the next question is I have this tincture that has like red root and red clover and stingilla.
And those are supposedly for lymphatic.
Um, have you heard of that also?
Yeah.
So there's different herbs that could help live.
But remember, what your lymphatics are.
Your lymphatics are like, uh, are an open-ended capillary system.
And I liken them to, uh, like your storm sewers on the side of your street.
And if the storm sewers get clogged with leaves, they're not going to work very well.
And you have a big brain form on your front yard is going to flood.
So you want to keep that those lymphatic vessels open.
Well, what are in, in practical purposes, somebody with breast cancer, that all that, uh, those, those excess of cells that are there, and you're trying to kill the cancer cells.
Um, and you have, uh, you know, different parts of cells that will be broken down that they have to be carried out through the lymphatic system there, like a clog of leaves.
And you want to keep that movie.
Otherwise, you know, you could get stasis of that limb, and then I could back up to the rest of the breast tissue, or, you know, anything, uh, the downside or the upside of that river.
And you could get, you know, like a day, block that flow.
So, always you want to be working on the badic drainage techniques, because that's how you get real poisons.
Uh, you, even without having cancer or something like that, you have poisons from, from normal.
You know, at least produced by metabolic processes of a single cell.
But that's what your lymphatic system drains, it drains out that waste, because your cells, uh, undergo metabolic processes that they dump their waste in the spaces between the cells.
And it's completely dependent upon your lymph system to know those spaces.
So, uh, doing what you're doing is all great techniques, uh, motion, muscle contraction, uh, uh, working, uh, detoxifying through other organs, like your skin.
And you know, the sun would be, uh, exercising, so you're sweating more.
So you're basically the same type of soda experience in detoxification plus with exercise.
You're just helping with the badic flow.
So you're doing everything right.
It's not necessarily a sign that something is quote unquote rug, but it's the fact that you do have cancer there that you have a lot of extra waste.
That's the root out there.
Okay, because that's exactly like it actually was, I had pain, I mean, not high pain, but fullness and pain.
And I almost feel like, yeah, it's inflammatory.
And that was a good explanation is because of all those cancer cells, even as their, I believe they're dead or dying.
They have to now, the trash men have to come and get a mask.
That's right.
Okay, so that, and I also, I forgot to say I went for a chiropractic adjustment the same day.
So I did all of these things and it made it all made a difference.
But I do all of this regularly anyway.
I just don't know why it backed up this week, you know, like what made it sludge up.
Well, a lot of reasons, maybe you got more killing taking place.
Maybe you were exposed to more toxins.
Maybe, you know, so there's just a lot of possibilities there.
You yourself up over it could be a good thing. Maybe you're killing more cancer cells.
So we just, you gotta keep fighting the fight.
Good explanation. Thank you.
Dr. Connors.
I'm just curious in a situation like that.
How would a detox of, for a way, football, football, come in.
So there's lots of different ways to help with the panic flow.
She just mentioned several of them there.
Rebo indeed.
Do detox, foot baths, do eat coffee, edibles, do eat hot water bottle, cup press over your liver,
supporting liver pathways through nutrition, taking more milk, thistle.
You know, all these things are great things, great tools to help move live.
We have a bunch of more things like that in your body, your vibrator, the lip section too.
Absolutely. Another great technique.
I have a question concerning the right machine on when my, when my cancer was showing active,
I was doing the, the, the spiral for two hours and, and the double bubble for two hours.
And, and the all night DNA repair.
But now that it's stabilized and the chemo's over and I don't have to go back to the doctor for six months,
I'm wondering how, how often I should be doing, I run the DNA every night.
But how often I should do the other two, the cancer programs.
Who am I speaking with?
Pardon me?
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm, forgive me, Liz Schaffner.
Oh, okay, Liz.
So, are you, are you not running the programs that I gave you?
Absolutely, I'm running them.
Okay, and then you're doing, you're doing a lot of extra things.
So, a lot of people on this call are probably going to book and shoot to eat.
And, because they're not running a lot of day programs.
So, you have to do really what you're most comfortable with, I would hate to say,
oh, you don't have to do any more day programs, just run the night program.
Because I'm not God, I don't know if that's true.
But you also, I don't, I don't want you to be so consumed with your right that you feel like you have no other life during the day too.
Personally, I run, right during the day when I come home, I run the right while I'm sitting in my office,
I'm running the right and I'm running the right at night too.
So, of course, I'm not just sitting in my office all day.
I'm getting up and doing different things and going to see patients and stuff.
And I can't always run the right like I don't have it on right now because if I'm on the phone with somebody,
they typically go, what's that, what's that beeping noise?
I can't hear you very well because it appears, but so I'm constantly positive starting it.
So, I don't know, maybe I get two hours, maybe I get an hour during the day, a real right time.
But I think it's wise for everybody that if you are inclined to sit down and read a book or knit or watch TV
and be ready to write at that time, would be if that's possible, that would be beneficial.
So, you're getting some date of right-feet as well.
I'm just, I'm just talking to the inclination that the more right-feet the better, especially when your cancer is, you know,
in a fairly aggressive, angry state.
And then maybe, you know, less angry state, you could get by with less right-feet.
So, you just could have used your COVID sense there in a little bit.
And be sure you're prayed about it so you know that you're not making it as naked and not doing it as much as you should be doing it either so.
Right. Thank you, Dr. Colton.
You bet.
This is Dennis. I have another question.
The rife, too, by have the foam and supports have somehow slid in towards the middle of the two a little bit.
Is that an issue or a problem if I need to pull them back?
It's just a problem for me because I have a little OCD issue this, so I want to get a lucky nice.
So, I talk about two of two and go to it with like a little metal.
You know, take a piece of copper wire and bend it in like a hook and grab down it and pull it back.
And then put a little hot glue in there to have it stay there.
It's not going to affect its function at all though.
It's just a matter of, you know, what it looks like.
Okay, thank you.
We have a lot of questions.
That's what you get when you only allow really smart people to come here patients.
That's spent by a little secret technique.
So I just don't get as many questions.
So it's just fantastic.
So I need to leave more currently, I guess.
I'd like just opportunity to really thank you for these faithful weekend, weekly calls.
And being available to answer questions.
Thank you so much.
I agree.
And your patients, you have so much patience.
I thought you're talking about that patience, you're talking about it.
Because I, I know questions are repeatedly asked because you might miss a Zoom call or whatever.
So we have a lot of patients.
Oh, absolutely.
Now, next week after you just said our Facebook list or Wednesday Zoom calls, I think we're going to have to do next week's on Tuesday, but I will post it on Facebook.
Because I'm going to be out of town next week on Wednesday.
And Michelle is going to be out of town next week on Wednesday.
She has to go home visit, I think, at least.
So we're going to do it on Tuesday, but I'll post it.
And it will be a different link.
So just be aware of that.
I'll post that up on the Facebook page.
Would we do that for sure?
Okay.
So thank you so much.
Thank you for your kindness, your words of encouragement, heartfelt.
We appreciate it.
Oh, what we do, we can get very discouraging.
But we have patients that, you know, everything we do just sometimes doesn't work.
And I'm wise enough to know that it's not in my control.
And I'm not the healer, but it's so saddens me.
I feel like I let people down in ways.
And I know that I didn't know what's in God's hands, but in my flesh, it just breaks my heart.
We had a couple of patients that passed away this week.
And I don't think they were any, they weren't anybody that was on the Facebook page.
I understand everybody that's listening in the Zoom call right now, you started with us last September or later.
We've allowed a few people that started with us on that.
When we first started this Facebook page, I allowed some people in there and started prior to that.
But, you know, I've been doing this for most 20 years with patients.
And so everybody that you're listening to all the people at Facebook that are encouraging you with such patience in the last 12 months.
So we get patients that have were given, you know, three months to live and they've lived four years and they pass away.
If we've had relationships with them for four years, it's just heartbreaking sometimes.
So we cherish your prayers.
Just to ask that you continue to pray for us for encouragement, for protection, and for wisdom.
Because without that, we would be completely lost.
Thank you guys for all that you do.
You guys really make this clear because it's not about us, it's about all you guys.
So thank you so much.
Thank you doctor.
Thank you.
All right, with that, we will end it and we'll get this up on Facebook as soon as possible.
And I will remake that.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Bye.